[Musique]
de tous les départements français aucun
n'est peut-être aussi intrigant et
méconnue que ce petit coup de france au
coeur de l'océan indien qu'on appelle
mayotte
à mi chemin entre madagascar et
l'afrique cette île volcanique est aussi
la plus ancienne de l'archipel des
comores dont elle tire sa culture
musulmane et ses influences multiples
avec son lagon bleu et sa biodiversité
unique mayotte pourrait faire la une des
brochures touristiques
pourtant derrière la carte postale ce
101e département et le plus pauvre de
france
77 % de la population y vit sous le
seuil de pauvreté dans des logements
précaires et un tiers de ses habitants
n'a pas accès à l'eau courante
mayotte une île jeunes avec onze mille
naissances par an et un habitant sur
deux de moins de 18 ans mais aussi
surpeuplé officiellement 300 mille
personnes se partagent un territoire 20
fois plus petit que la corse pression
démographique pression migratoire aussi
la moitié de sa population est d'origine
étrangère et chaque jour la police
reconduits aux frontières des
sans-papiers comoriens pour la plupart
en 2018 les mahorais font la grève et
protestent contre l'insécurité galopante
et l'immigration massive
comment ce coin de paradis qui s'est
battu pour devenir français fait-il pour
garder la tête hors de l'eau exception
française sentiment d'être oubliés
qui sont ces habitants qui vivent à 8000
kilomètres de l'hexagone et qu'ont ils à
nous dire
entre grandeur et misère nous sommes
allés à leur rencontre
le jour se lève sur l'île aux parfums il
est 5 heures mais pour ces lycéens qui
habite tsingoni c'est déjà l'heure de
prendre le chemin du lycée
en terminale générale
évoque cette année là à la blague très
difficile pour ceux qui en ont été
beaucoup de courbes début de l'année à
cause de quoi
bon match
s'est décidé de leur corps pour éviter
ce problème quoi
à l'école de carrick en sentant empire
mariam et sa soeur se rendent tous les
jours au lycée gustave eiffel de kahani
qui est régulièrement le théâtre
d'affrontements violents entre bandes
rivales de jeunes jets de pierres
passage à tabac mais aussi meurtre à
l'armé blanche cette violence chronique
est devenu un vrai fléau en avril 2021
deux lycéens étaient assassinées en
moins d'une semaine une violence
choquante mais loin d'être
exceptionnelle ni réduite à un seul
quartier puisqu'elle touche tout le
territoire mahorais où le taux
d'homicide est le plus élevé de l'union
européenne
ce matin aucun chauffeur de bus met en
grève mais personne ne sait combien de
temps cela peut durer
à la même heure miftah où se prépare
pour aller travailler
né d'une mère mahoraise et d'un père
comoriens elle a grandi ici et fait une
partie de ses études d'infirmière en
métropole
[Musique]
vous partirez en 25 heures parce que ça
si ça se joue à pas grand-chose à ça
peut être à 5h10 là tu ça passe plus il
faut il faut faire on peut faire une
heure dit si j'exagère un peu mais pas
trop en même temps ici de génie parce
qu'on n'a pas assez de routes
donc voilà mayotte c'est chez moi
j'ai grandi ici j'ai fait mes études ici
la grande commande c'est chez moi aussi
je connais pas je connais pas plus que
ça je suis allé dans ma vie trois fois
oui
on espère que ça se passe bien tous les
matins quand tous les moteurs le choc tu
faisais que ça se passait bien
moi quand je commençais à 4h30 j'étais
déjà sur le terrain donc j'ai participé
rto et puis maintenant j'ose plus
romagnol ya pas mal de jeunes qui vont
plus à l'école et qui essaye de voir
l'argent facile on se fait agresser à
tout moment toutes les maisons d'un an
ya des barreaux parce que les gens se
font
attaquer chez eux donc on n'est ni
tranquille chez soi ni à l'extérieur
aujourd'hui tu envoies ton enfant à
l'école
tu abordes tu as peur qu'on t'appelle
d'enfants et à la mort voilà mais
c'est triste c'est hyper triste on n'a
même pas on en est pas là pour définir
ce qui se passe ici là je réfléchis tu
deviens faux parce que c'est d'aimer à
quel moment et cc c'est parti à soupe en
clôture barbelée caméra le lycée a des
allures de prison avec ses gendarmes aux
avant postes
après 20 minutes de route mariam on
retrouve ses camarades
d'après l'insee 55% des mahorais âgés de
21 à 29 ans quitterait le territoire
pour poursuivre leurs études entre 25 %
à la réunion en cause le faible nombre
de cursus proposés et l'absence totale
de certaines filières est ce que tu peux
nous raconter ce qui s'est passé
mercredi dernier ici
quand tu étais en classe dans l'après
midi il n'arriva on n'arrive pas à faire
un mois sans
el prat paquet par des jeunes mercredi
on était en dessous et
on entendait des filles et qui criait
il y avait aussi deux guest très bons
gènes qui sentait tout le monde et été
excité
c'était en panique
et est-ce que vous avez une idée de qui
sont ces gens qui attaquent un lycée
c'est des garçons des fois ils mettent
des robes de filles des perruques et des
foyers ils cachent leur visage pour
qu'on les voit pas est ce que ça vous
rassure le papier des gendarmes non
c'est nouveau ça nous rassure va de soi
puisqu'il ne prévient pas en venant et
le gendarme robert labails
ben lancé des cailloux par ici et
elle s'en remet donc ça la présence des
gendarmes ça les dissuade absolument pas
d'attaquer le lycée ou non ils attaquent
quand même métier des regards et des
fois le proviseur y est la tenue des
cours et des médiateurs et vous appelle
le bus les bus et on vienne nous
récupérer en dépassionnant en prépa pour
dans la jambe ça arrive à d'autres
lycées mais
met à tanis et c'est devenu de leurs
habitudes
serge changer glissé
[Applaudissements]
oui mais on peut pas raisonner en fin
d'année donc
on aimait que
béchard a media luz où on vienne à
l'école sans problème la conscience
tranquille
et prendre aussi la phase 1 3 me
ça
ou je sais pas mais on est un peu
à l'écart
n'est pas établi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la mer l'avastin
qui se cache derrière ces guerres de
clans dans les villages où tout le monde
se connaît la loi du silence prévaut par
peur des représailles mais derrière ces
conflits se cache une jeunesse en
souffrance à mayotte moins de la moitié
des enfants de 3 ans vont à l'école
contre 98% métropole et ils seraient
plus de sept mille mineurs isolés pour
un enfant né à mayotte la scolarité
devenu un enjeu de taille faire des
études sans interruption est l'un des
seuls moyens de devenir français avec le
mariage on comprend les frustrations que
l'école engendre il paraît premier en
france à mes parents on a des
spécificités
est ce qu'on est vraiment considérés
comme les français n'y a pas de réponse
est à jamais de réponse en fait
on n'a jamais vu un ministre venir parce
que il ya eu trois meurtres où il ya eu
une inondation
voilà peut-être que c'était
mayotte ces français c'est un
département et tout ça il ya à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
si je peux
de l eau tiède c'est après quand tu vas
dans une famille c'est tout le monde
ça va
[Musique]
ici j'ai vite de passer très très tôt
parce que parfois il ya des jeunes qui
traînent ici et même mon collègue a
failli se faire agresser une fois donc
on se met si
regardez c'est toutes les maisons en
tôle donc c'est des gens en situation
irrégulière
[Musique]
ça lui
servant son cousin qui s'appelle farid
sinon vous ça va
français ou sans papiers 66% de la
population mahoraise vit dans un
quartier délaissé près de la moitié des
habitants sont étrangers et 12% en
situation irrégulière ils débarquent des
comores mais aussi d'afrique et du moyen
orient dans l'espoir d'une vie meilleure
l'immigration économique urgence
sanitaire réfugié politique les raisons
sont nombreuses pour venir à mayotte
même si la spécificité reste
l'immigration familiale en provenance de
l'île voisine en jouant farid mahorais
et anne âmes d'origine comorienne ont
passé leur enfance ici à combani
derrière ces murs de tôle qui ont
remplacé les banga traditionnels du coup
on fait le petit tour là comme ça vous
allez bien voir le quartier
les bidonvilles les maisons toll
mais moi ça me gêne pas tandis et randy
le bizet bideau ville parce que déjà
c'est là où j'ai vécu des plus petits
jusqu'à maintenant c'est toujours la
maison trois centres ya des gens qui
vont pas aimer mais avec moi
voyez la rivière là il ya tout c'est un
peu dégueulasse
bah oui mais on n'a pas de choix c'est
là où on lave nos vêtements la partir de
18h là tout le monde vont descendre et
c'est les mamans les papas dont vous
voyez c'est trop sale mais tu vois et à
la petite langue qui nettoie les
marmites tout ça c'est pas bon mais il
n'y a pas de choix parce que peut pas
faire autrement on n'a pas les moyens
d'acheter quelque chose qu'on ne peut
pas avoir du coup l'eau c'est important
vaut mieux que je trouve pas manger que
j'ai 2 le jeu peu moins vivant un petit
peu mais sans l'eau on peut pas vivre
c'est là on a vécu des plus petits du
cours d'eau toujours on va continuer
espérons qu'avec ça va changer un jour
là les conditions de vie parfois c'est
difficile
des gens qu'ils vivent
avec bien
même pour manger on voit pas mal de
diabétiques par exemple et qu'on
travaille avec avec des protocoles mais
des fois c'est à
c'est pas possible d'appliquer ce
protocole parce que la personne n'a pas
mangé n'a pas toujours à manger vous
savez la pauvreté on a toujours connu à
mayotte
tout le monde et épouse de l'emploi il
ya beaucoup d'entre aide dont costa ne
se voyait pas ordinaire
ça va en fait et
l'italie stick et le sucre et les bas ce
matin
la glycémie était vers les basses dans
le corps et auquel le qu'elle mange un
peu truc
mais sans voix dit peiné qu'avoir asile
au nicaragua shito
s'est dit et il me dit il n'ya même pas
de pain donc là je lui donnais une
compote qui est bien sucré ça va
remonter un peu mais c'est immédiate
laisse avec 206 elle mange pas grand
chose si je parle qu'on lui donne rien
elle risque de faire un malaise
j'ai pas le temps de faire un malaise
c'est encourageant du stangala la forme
[Musique]
aux ailes et on a tous mal
pour défendre
je sais
c'est pas normal tout ça peut pas de
route rien du tout hélas même pas d'être
militaire moi m'a dit je suis né ici à
mayotte
quelques problèmes explique nous un peu
bas genre je suis à la mairie j'ai
demandé mon acte de naissance moins
trois mois jusque là pas j'ai fait du
retour leur demandent des solutions ils
peuvent même pas me répondre et c'est
compliqué je suis là tu me planquer on
est tous bloqués en attendant ben je
bricole vous pouvez aller voir là où je
travaille
mais bon c'est pas légal une fois on n'a
pas à le papier pour circuler c'est ce
qu'on a fait bloquer jusqu'à ménage vit
sans patrie et je m'en sors mon sort
comme je peux ces chiens là
j'achète de moto en occasion j'essaie de
les réparer et puis les revendre pour
pouvoir
être sur vous
tous les profits sont là mon acte de
naissance
après il dit sur le registre il fait
toujours pas
1992 ailier 1993 elle vieillit pas 1994
est lié donc il ya un truc qui cloche à
l'intérieur et ils veulent pas un métier
russe
d'après mon défenseur de droits que je
suis allé voir là-bas au tribunal genre
je suis bloqué
il les choses parfaitement illégal afin
moi j'ai des enfants jamais on m'a
demandé ma feuille d'impôts pour
inscrire à l'école publique mon enfant
anne le guern et directrice du village
d'eva une association créée en 2014 qui
offre la scolarité vos enfants qui n'y
ont pas accès qu'ils soient français
étrangers ou sans papiers il serait
aujourd'hui 8000 à être dans cette
situation
l'objectif leur offrir des savoirs
fondamentaux notamment le français sur
une île qui parle son propre dialecte le
shimaoré comme tous les territoires qui
subissent une pression démographique
importante liée à l'immigration eh ben
il ya la montée des extrêmes et donc il
ya aussi un fort racisme envers les
comoriens principalement les comoriens
mais on a aussi une émigration
centrafrique on leur demande des choses
qui peuvent pas fournir enfin tout pour
qu'ils y accèdent pas et quand il arrive
à déposer un dossier on n'est pas sûr
qu'il ait pas classé verticale on est
même certain que certaines communes ne
dresse pas de listes d'attentes donc du
coup si un peu de place le dossier il
est détruit l'enfant il existe pas
du coup actuellement vu que l'eau a un
petit problème
du coût des associations acheter des
bouteilles pour les petits pour éviter
qu'ils aient mal au ventre ou autre
chose la mayotte on peut pas souvent il
ya des problèmes d'eau du coup quand tu
as les moyens tu peux te permet
d'acheter des bouteilles mais quand t'as
pas les moyens tu fais avec soi l'esprit
je sais que les gens disent et souvent
il à bout pour pouvoir la à boire mais
là avec le manganèse c'est bien le
mondial est en excès peut provoquer des
troubles neurologiques et altérer le
développement de l'enfant au nom de
potable coupures récurrentes le problème
du traitement de l'eau à mayotte n'est
pas nouveau et fait plus largement écho
à la question sanitaire plus que
préoccupante sur l'île je crois que
c'est la première fois dans ma vie
professionnelle que j'ai le sentiment de
faire de l'humanitaire et pas du social
et pas de l'éducation jeu fait de
l'humanitaire parce que les enfants ont
faim et que dans le projet ben il faut
on l'est on essayait de les nourrir et
moi quand je nourris les enfants on me
reproche de nourrir des enfants
comoriens et donc de favoriser ou voir
même d'inciter à l'immigration j'en ai
vu faire des malaises oui je peux pas
dire après ils ont bataillé en train et
bien ça c'est pas acceptable non plus
parce que ça voudrait dire que les
mahorais ne nourrissent pas les enfants
mais en même temps me demande de pas les
nourrir parce qu'on est dans la
contradiction 116 clairement c'est la
montée des extrêmes face à une situation
qui est devenue invivable pour tout le
monde sur l'île ce territoire est trop
petit pour accueillir tout le monde mais
une fois qu'on arrive ici on est
prisonniers ici même avec un titre de
séjour on n'a pas le droit de circuler
en europe parce qu'on veut contenir tout
le monde sur l'île
évidemment que l'on est assis sur une
poudrière enfin moi je leur jette même
pas la pierre
bloquée c'est le cas d'anne sam pour qui
le mot clandestins est encore difficile
à prononcer né à anjouan il a aussi fait
la traversée avec sa mère sur un
kwassa-kwassa ces pirogues de fortune
qui arrive au nord de l'île le point le
plus proche à 70 kilomètres des côtes
comoriennes la première fois que tu as
traversé pour comment ça s'est passé
lorsqu'on m'a dit j'avais
c'est en six ans comme ça jusqu'où je
voyais et le pathos à ça tu t'en sors et
je mange je viens parfois ça sera de sa
joie et du coup j'ai craint que cela
m'en fais toi tu es mené par
les amis les potes quand qu'il vient ici
nous appelons fait et quand ils nous
appellent et une met la pression ici
c'est là c'est l'appétit il ya des
choses dans un pays vous réussissez vous
voilà et du coup ça te fait penser moi
même j'ai mis la pression aux pareil
pour germain jamais assez pour que là on
vient même avis aux audi a5 et au long
cou s'appelait pas cher qu'à l'époque en
2009 ça fait pas acheter pas cher de
guerre simplement tu arrivé en 2009
aujourd'hui on en 2021
j'imagine que tu as tu as essayé d'avoir
des papiers il y avait une dame là au
bureau à la
pause et de tant de questions il y en a
qui m'ont fait mal quelque 600 heures
finale dames on m'a demandé pourquoi
venir à mayotte quoi rester pas h et
soir pour venir des puants jours à
chercher à l'école ici chez papa et où
je suis moi on a eu un peu de
discussions et j ai madame maman moi je
suis venu chercher une vie normale et ne
demande est là bas y'a pas normal une
voix et finalement on a discuté jusqu'au
moment dit il faut il faut il faut les
tournées chez toi et sita dans la photo
tant à faire ici et ça m'a bouleversé
franchement sorti la branche moi ça m'a
fait pleurer pleurer et je me sens un
terrain j'étais en fait toi si tu avais
des papiers
mais si j'avais des papes et je redis
pas rester ainsi dire émotionnellement
mais en france on est trop proche ou
ailleurs quoi
tu n'aimes pas cette île je suis bien je
suis bien mais en même temps je suis pas
bien ce que et je travaillais pas à nos
mamans comme les autres on se cache on
contrôle il n'y a pas la police la
municipale marché on travaille mais en
cachette en fait n'a pas la liberté en
fait à tout moment tu peux aujourd'hui
te faire arrêter et on peut te renvoyer
aux as
même après
13 ans de présence sur l'île aloi nous
savons oui c'est ou chez toi non non non
moi je suis moi c'est senna ou cheminée
dans le champ selon johanne score
bien sûr cela ou jeunesse là où il ya ma
famille c'est là où
se sentir chez soi et en sécurité c'est
un sentiment que tous les habitants
aimeraient partager aux beaucoup de
mahorais qui ont leurs racines ici et
qui ont connu mayotte avant qu'il ne
devienne un département français le
changement assez radical de lille est un
sujet sensible à ce cas et sa femme
laure qui habite tout au sud en témoigne
bonjour à ce cas bonjour ça va quoi tu
vas bien karim ou ben merci chez moi
donc venez passer ta maison hollande
c'est moi maintenant c'est bien ri la
vie appuiera
et alors tu installé ici depuis qu'on
bat depuis trois ans maintenant je me
suis installé ici avec ma femme et mes
enfants donc tranquillement je suis
macho man ray à la base pas le diplôme
c'est compliqué eh bien il fallait que
j'avance donc du coup je me suis engagé
dans l'armée où j'ai fait vingt ans
l'armée d'accord la dent maintenant je
suis à la retraite militaire donc tu vas
rester ici tu sais tu es racines car
c'est mes racines certes oui mais même
mettre ça va un moment ça va c'est un
tout je peux rester ici mais je peux
rentrer métropole aussi et puis maillot
de sa change il ya des lots jour d'hui
ça va demain ça ira peut-être pas mais
c'est la france tout à part on n'a pas
les mêmes lois on n'a pas les mêmes
règles parce que dès qu'on parle de
mayotte il faut faire un arrêté spécial
mayotte mayotte c'est l'eldorado donc
mettre tout avec plus la misère qui a
autour de mayotte entre la france et
l'afrique les comores et madagascar le
faut des migrations s'est enfin on est
allé dans le nord de mayotte s'est pas
l'eldorado à nancy on dirait que la
situation est plus calme dans le sud on
est calme ça c'est sûr on a encore de la
chance tout se passe bien mais dans
certains l'endroit mayotte mais n'ont
cédé des zones de non droit quand tu
vois des gens qui sont prêts à travers
70 km en bateau tout pour venir ici
s'installer qu'est ce que tu penses de
ces gens là mais
ils sont courageux c'est inhumain parce
que moi j'ai je travaillais bien et j'ai
déjà vu des ces barques la rentrée ici
illégalement et
c'est compliqué parce que quand on voit
une barque où il ya au moins 43
personnes à des chèvres et ou à ici une
vague tout peut basculer et ils prennent
le risque de venir ici pour
officiellement il ya deux cent cinquante
mille habitants sur l'île en réalité
alors s associent samanyana plus que ça
tu dit ça il ya déjà que ce même pas
identifié il ya des gens qui sont ces
même pas qu'ils existent là il ya des
villages et dans la forêt on découvre
des gens tous les jours tous les jours
et ça ça n'existait pas quand tu étais
jeune talent avant on pouvait se balader
allez allez faire un petit camping à des
petits bee ware et les amis sur une
plage tranquillement aujourd'hui je peux
pas aujourd'hui à chaque fois qu'on va
se déplacer on va se déplacer en groupe
à la maison il ya des caméras partout
dans le monde donnait tout s'arrête
mayotte il ya des belles choses mais qui
sait si joris est beau on peut vivre
paisiblement
bientôt on accueille tout le monde on
accueille tout le monde
bat les clandestins non
c'est différent mayotte est le seul
département français où le droit du sol
est limité pour qu'un enfant né sur le
territoire mahorais obtiennent la
nationalité française il faut qu'au
moins l'un de ses parents résident sur
le territoire français de manière
régulière et ininterrompue depuis plus
de trois mois lors la femme daska est
arrivé il y a dix ans elle est
professeur de svt au collège de bouéni
moi je suis venu pour le travail je
reste parce que mon travail me plaît et
que je suis motivé et pia vous avez eu
le courage de bunia côté support pour la
suite qu'annick on a vu aussi
est-ce que j'ai bien l'impression qu'il
n'ya pas unanimes il n'y a pas
d'évènement à mayotte mais c'est vrai
que là depuis deux ans ça s'est accéléré
ouais ouais nan mais franchement elle
c'est là on sature en fait de tous deux
arriver à avoir des élèves à la fin de
la troisième qui savent pas lire et
écrire si on a beau faire de
l'accompagnement différents sièges à un
moment donné ces moyens là c'est
beaucoup plus tôt qu'il faut les faire
le fait qu'ils aient pas papier le fait
qu'on leur dise à la fin de la troisième
c'est un pas de papiers sita c'est un
bête tu seras pas pris dans l'hélice et
puisqu'il n'ya pas de place puis après
le rsm aussi pour les six pour des
français c'est pour des français en fait
on se rend compte mais pour être
apprenti me fait rien c'est donc s'ils
viennent d'accueillir mais je casse les
seins nus on leur donne de l'espoir et
puis à la fin on leur dit quoi non mais
t'as pas de papiers des écoutes
accroche-toi mais fait pas de conneries
que obligé de motiver certains
professeurs est-ce qu'il y en a qui
baissent les bras rapport à cette
situation les gens qui se bouge ici le
problème c'est qu'à un moment donné on
va les arrêter parce que
l'administration est compliqué parce que
on va on va toujours lui dire oui mais
toi comme tu fais ça vas-y fais en plus
c'est en plus les maternités elles ne
peuvent plus les sages plein d un peu
fait elle n'en peuvent plus ils sont
toujours en grève on a il est membre les
profs ils n'en peuvent plus mais moi je
vais vous dire ça fait dix ans que je
suis ici et un moment donné
je travaillais pas parler de soi auquel
tranquille
mais non mais c'est vrai que pour une
fois qu'on a la parole on se dit mais
est-ce que ce qu'on leur a apporté est
ce que ce système là ce qui est bon pour
mayotte gros point d'interrogation
non il ya toute une refonte en fait ici
de l'école j'aimerais dire il savait pas
parler français rv à leurs maîtres de
l'anglais de l'espagnol pourquoi momento
n'y a pas quelque chose à date adapté
pour eux mais ça va être ça va prendre
plus longtemps que
[Applaudissements]
moi je parle je sors du boulot tu me
demande de parler de marriott ben oui ça
fait dix ans que je suis là si je mets
pas ma note je serai pas quelle idée de
rester là et lille a dit mme ayotte
petite soeur pauvres de france a
aujourd'hui besoin de temps pour
continuer à se construire à se met à
grandir un milliard et demi d'euros sont
injectés chaque année pour son
développement un chiffre qui questionne
pour ses habitants surtout s'il eldorado
semble avoir disparu l'as mahoraise elle
ne semble pas oublié et sous la
poudrière se cache une richesse
insoupçonnée
mayotte parviendra-t-elle demain à
sortir de cette urgence permanente
jusqu'à présent lille tient mais à quel
prix et pour combien de temps
[Musique]